so it doesn't stop there former Miss
Teen USA cami Crawford tweeted that she
had been told before meeting Donald
Trump that Donald Trump didn't like
black people here is a tweet from kami
Crawford who was named Miss Teen USA
2010 she said she first met Trump when
she was 17 the most Trump T al spill for
the day is this when I was 17 I met mr.
Trump for the first time as Miss Teen
USA as the first woman of color
dot-dot-dot and then here is part two of
kami Crawford's tweet about this to win
the title in almost a decade
I was forewarned prior to meeting him
that quote mr. Trump doesn't like black
people so don't take it and she went on
to say don't take it personally Crawford
was reportedly told that if Trump isn't
extremely welcoming to her don't worry
it's just because she's black but if he
is welcoming to kami Crawford then it
must be because kami Crawford is the
quote type of black that Donald Trump
likes and she said sure enough after I
was warned about him I saw him in action
and witnessed him completely snub a
black contestant at Miss Universe
rehearsals but apparently Crawford was
the type of black person that Trump
liked saying that Trump would basically
tote her around brag about how beautiful
she was how well-spoken she was she's so
smart look at how smart she is she said
on Twitter that she is indeed supporting
Democratic presidential nominee Hillary
Clinton this is of course making
right-wingers totally disregard her
plant claims but the basic picture
that's being painted here when we talk
about the type of black that Donald
Trump likes when we talk about him
parading her around saying look at how
smart and well-spoken she is this is you
know when you hear from people I like
certain black people and what they're
referring to is light-skinned black
people that in their eyes don't quote
act black we've heard this so many times
Pat this is such a common thing I love
black people
I love certain black people and it
always seems to be black people fitting
a certain caricature isn't it yeah and
if you remember too in the last debate
when asked about race relations he
responded with inner city
he's a dancer on Rainier city's yeah I
mean that's not why you were asked about
here he's trying to give a wink and a
nod to his white constituency no doubt
about it and it's yet another unproven
allegation right just another claim to
be skeptical of of course it fits
perfectly into the picture that we've
built up of Donald Trump based heavily
in part on the things Trump himself has
actually said Warby Parker is offering a
free five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing